>>A WE ABSOLE CHAO MANY CA
ISOMF OUR H BILLIONS
M T IS NN TURMOIL BOARD FIRED IA
FRIDAY.
HEIRESN'REDS THREATENING TO FIRM
TRAGED ADD DETAILS
OFLTMAN'S
T SUFFICIENTLY
CANDITD BUT DIDN'TDELVE INTO
>>OW MA HUGETNER AA BI.
THE CEO NADELLA ALREADY HIRED
ALTMAN HIMSE APARTNERSP ICROSO
HIT ., THIS IS NOT YOUR
AVERAGE CORPORATE FLE.
ONCE THOUGHT TO BE SCISTION.E
TOMAN-LIKE THAN EVER BEFORENDMP
TASKS NORMALLY PEOPLE AND DO THE
D -HIVOT
PODCAST.
THISMESSTALKTOND
CLOSE TO THIS.
>> YEAH.
STEPACD GIVES
THE CONTEXT WHATS FOR
ED AWANDW NING RIGHT NOWTHE EMP
REPORTED, HAD GOTTEN TOGETHER,
WAS INCOMPETEND GOING TO D WORKN
IN AEW BOARD BRINGK
D ALSO NAMED
BROCKMAN, WHO FTSA. DON'T KNOW
MICROSOFT WI CA NEW
DIVISION.
CERTAINLY HAS AN INVESTM
AVTOE TS DOESN'T
KEEP
LEONFF0,
COMMITMENTS. KEE
CRIS THIS BOTO STEP DOWN.
CHOICE. ITH THAT WOULD IT
GE ANYTHING?
IF THE BOA CHANGEDY WAY TOEVRSEP
TH?MEMBERF MICROSOFT
>> LA R .
T COULD
COULD COME BACT A CONTROL, OVE -
TO.Y Y FO
O HANDLED
STOCK KILLED FRIDAY AND F , ROS
MANATOES A REALLY BAD
IS NOT HOWONE OF THE MOST OYEESS
IMPORTANMPANIES OF THE AAGE, ATO
NEW COANY, CEO TE
INTO.
WHATIMATELY PRECEDED H
FIRI
WHAT WAS THEREEMENT?
ITRIED TOT OUT OF
ONE OF THEUEF TRANSPAREN
KIE WAS A , BUT
DE LIEDABOUN'T BEN IT.ONE OF T
FIRING N RECANTE
THAT HSUMA
SIGNED THAT , WHICH WAS IRD.
THE CHIEF SCIENTIST.
A -REGARDENOLOGIST ANDRIGHT IN .
THAT KIND OF THI. SONG
I DON'OW WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN TO THIS BOARD
THERE PEOPLE LEFT
YOU CAN'T OPERATE DOTHINK IF TOW
THESUSPECT IT'S VERY TOHE
G IN A REVOLUTIONARY RUNNERS
VISION ANDIRS ANFULLY FORTHCOMIN
FFWAYS
HIM.
, ET CERA., OR
INSTEAD TOOK THIS RATH --
THEY'RE VE- THEY'RE CONCERNED AE
LSE, T
IFIC ISSUESANGCIFI ISSUE EITHERR